welcome to this video playing stupid
chess from the US let's play the tango
didn't play that for a while so quite a
decent opening ok now we probably
transpose yeah we do to the to the names
oh the Zurich variation of the news oh
yeah now White has why choice can play
before if I all kinds of moves in this
position yeah I need to go to back to be
eight
again this typical closed position
typical for for the Zurich and it's been
a while that I wrote the chapter on this
book on this line in the book I've
probably forgot all of it this is early
very early it's a fairly normal move
structure on the structural point of
view it's only very early here just this
night c5 not sure if it should be should
be play well move though you want to
spend more time night h5 is may be
possible but not sure if it is good
let's go here
keep it simple and now try to try to
make sure that this night is Sam nicely
anchored okay or this one so nothing was
nicely anchored but at least there are
some exchanges and this usually is
helpful for black the bishop is also not
that great on on a1a typical plan now is
Bishop to d7 and getting a piece to be
five nights e7 be should be 50 97 to be
five or whoopsie eight first year let's
do this first to irritate him a bit and
that's also Queen e8 create yeah to play
Bishop b5 next or bishop a 4-bit should
be five it's may be more precise we are
still why not I don't mind to exchange
the so-called bad bishops bishop because
I need some space for my pieces and the
exchanges rather welcome yep and he
avoids it so night to be six maybe night
be 64 or something like that
and just do what can just take it
and this was weird why yeah a bit of a
sudden end to this game yeah I sometimes
don't upload very good wins but this was
our actually interesting because of the
the defensive set up I think this is
quite quite okay for blankets a complete
block of the queenside that this picture
is not doing so much and you have those
ideas him the two bishops I'm a
well-known bishop at hand but they don't
do so much here and in general it is not
so easy to make something of the bishops
in a completely symmetrical position as
this doesn't have any pawn dynamics in
it yeah but not c4 course was very very
helpful thanks for watching